Hi, everybody. I'm Marika Speranza, and I'm a
GSK employee. And I'm here on behalf of GSK to
introduce the AACR-GSK Gertrude Elion
Gertrude Award. Gertrude Elion was a pioneer
biochemist and pharmacologist whose background work
revolutionized modern medicine and drug discovery.
While at Burnham Welcome, that is one of GSK legacy company, she developed
some of the first effective therapeutics for leukemia and other cancers,
as well as antivirals that transformed the treatment of infection disease.
Remarkably, she achieved those milestones at a time
where women were rarely seen, and let alone welcome in the
laboratory. So that was very remarkable.
Her discovery changed the life of millions of patients.
And that's not only earned a Nobel Prize in 1988,
but it also fundamentally shaped our understanding of
rational mechanism-based drug design.
The Gertrude Elion Award celebrate this legacy by
supporting exceptionally early career investigators who continue to
push the boundaries for cancer research.
So this year, it is my very honor and pleasure to introduce our
speaker, Dr. Carmen Li. Dr. Carmen is an assistant professor of
cancer biology at the University of Pennsylvania, and a core investigator
of the Basser Center for BRCA. She earned her AB
from Princeton University and then moved to MIT
for a PhD. She continued her postdoc work at the
Harvard Medical School, focusing of memory cell state plasticity
under genetic and physiological cancer risk factors.
Her lab at UPenn investigate the driving mechanism and
targetable vulnerability of hereditary cancers, as
well as the implication for sporadic cancers by combining
genetic mouse models, organoids, and genomic tools.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Carmen Li, who will deliver a
lecture entitled, "Harness Insight from Chromatin Priming
from Early Interception of Basal Like Breast Cancer."
Hi, everyone, and thank you, Dr. Speranza, for the very kind
introduction. I'm deeply honored and humbled to be selected by
the AACR for the Gertrude B. Elion Award for Cancer Research.
And to get this recognition and support for a new investigator
like me and my lab,
I'm incredibly grateful. And thank you for the AACR for
supporting young labs like ours. And so today, I'm very excited
to share ongoing work in our lab supported by this award.
As Dr. Speranza mentioned, I'm a new assistant professor
in the Department of Cancer Biology at the University of Pennsylvania,
and I started my lab about a year ago.
We're broadly interested in studying the development of hereditary
cancer that's driven by inherited
mutations in various tumor suppressor genes that can
give to substantially elevated risks of cancer development in different
tissue types. We study that both under baseline condition as well as
under physiological stress, such as with pregnancy,
obesity, and aging. And our central goals are to
uncover mechanistic drivers for the early onset of these
diseases, as well as to identify opportunities for early detection
and early intervention. And we believe that the
insights coming from these hereditary diseases have important
implications for the parallel early drivers in the
sporadic form of the same cancer type, given the high degree of molecular
similarity between the sporadic and hereditary forms of the same cancer type.
And so, central to our approach is to use precisely
designed, genetically engineered mouse models to mimic the
germline heterozygous state of the disease, and also to capture
the very early
stage of the
cancer development in a physiological and tractable manner.
And this approach largely stems from my graduate training, with Dr.
Tyler Jacks at MIT, to use mouse models for cancer studies.
And that inspired me to develop a new mouse model,
to study BRCA1-associated hereditary breast cancer.
That's back when I was a postdoc with Dr.
Joan Brugge at Harvard Medical School, and that became a focus of my lab
today, which I'm very excited to talk about how we use this new mouse
model to uncover interesting and unexpected chromatin
changes that's associated with higher cancer
risk and early onset of this hereditary cancer type.
And so, by way of introduction, we know that BRCA1 is
an important tumor suppressor gene that plays a major role in
maintaining genome integrity by repairing DNA
damage. And women and men who are born with a single inactivating
mutation of BRCA1 have much higher risk of
developing breast cancer, up to 80% chance in their
lifetime in women mutation carriers, compared to the general
population of non-carriers at about 13%
lifetime risks.
In addition to that, the age of cancer onset also tends to be much
earlier, by about one to two decades.
So this high degree of cancer predisposition is usually
explained by the two hit hypothesis that's initially proposed
by Dr. Alfred Knudson in the 1970s, which describes
that carriers of germline mutations in
tumor suppressor genes like BRCA1,
they're only one more hit away or one more mutation away from full gene
loss, compared to non-carriers, where two
functional copies of the gene have to be inactivated in the
same cell in order for cancer to develop, which is a much
more rare event.And so this probabilistic model
is intuitive, is elegant, is certainly not
wrong. But I was interested in asking if there is
any additional non-mutually exclusive explanation for this
high degree of cancer predisposition.
And so to directly ask this question, I developed a new mouse
model to
mimic the BRCA1 drumline heterozygous state in the
mammary gland. And we did this with the help of the late Dr.
David Livingston at Dana-Farber, and his postdoc at the time, Shailja
Pathania, who is now at UMass Boston.
So these heterozygous mice are born with a single inactivating mutation of
BRCA1 that is paired with a wild-type allele that is fully
functional. But we can later on delete that with the Cre recombinase
shown here. And these heterozygous mice for hereditary
cancer are compared to a wild-type model for sporadic breast
cancer, where both copies of BRCA1 are conditionally
wild type until Cre deletion.
Now these mice, even including the heterozygous mice, they don't
spontaneously develop mammary tumors, and in fact, their mammary
gland histology look completely normal,
just like what would you expect in human mutation carriers
compared to non-carriers breast tissues.
But we can inject their mammary gland with a lentivirus expressing the Cre
recombinase, which can then convert the
BRCA1
flox alleles into
null alleles, and therefore delete BRCA1 completely, either in
the wild-type background or a heterozygous background.
And doing so, in combination with deletion of p53, which
is frequently co-mutated with BRCA1 in human breast cancer,
we can develop tumors, mammary tumors, both in the
wild type and heterozygous background mice, and specifically
the basal subtype of breast cancer, which is associated with
human BRCA1 somatic or
drumline mutation, and it's a type of breast cancer that is very
aggressive and very difficult to treat in patients.
And so with this, we can ask the question, now that we can concurrently
inactivate BRCA1, both in the wild type and heterozygous
condition,
or background,
do these two types of mice develop tumors at the same time,
which will be the prediction of the two-hit hypothesis?
Interestingly, we
saw something very different. We saw that the heterozygous mice shown
here in orange, formed tumors earlier than the wild-type mice by
about 20 weeks ahead. And that's also true in a different mouse
model where we additionally target PTEN by using
CRISPR-Cas9, both in the lenti-Cre virus and the drumline of the mice.
And again, here, the heterozygous mice as a group developed
tumors earlier than the wild-type mice.
And these results are certainly unexpected according to the prediction of the
two-hit hypothesis,
and we have ruled out the trivial explanation that this difference, this
delay in tumor latency, is simply because
of a lower efficiency of the Cre recombinase to delete
two copies of BRCA1 in the wild-type background versus just
one copy in the heterozygous background.
In fact, we found that the Cre is highly efficient in deleting all the conditional
alleles in as early as four days after infection.
And so instead, our data suggests that there are intrinsic aberrations in
the heterozygous mammary gland that act independent from the
timing of full BRCA1 loss to promote cancer development.
And so we set off to look for this aberration, the
nature of this aberration or gene haploinsufficiency effect that
act in the heterozygous mammary gland independent from the timing
of BRCA1 full inactivation to accelerate cancer
development. And we've explored different directions based on
many interesting and exciting reports in the literature,
including gene expression changes in the epithelial or stromal
populations within the breast, or expansion of different cell
populations and signs of accumulated DNA damage.
But, in our system, what jumped out most strikingly was
chromatin accessibility changes in the mammary gland,
specifically in a type of epithelial cells called
secretory alveolar cells or AB cells, also
sometimes known as luminal progenitor cells or LAP cells,
that in the normal breast give rise to
the cells responsible for milk
production. And in the case of breast cancer, they are known as
the tumor cells of origin for basal-like breast cancer, based on
various human and mouse studies.
So when we performed ATAC-seq chromatin accessibility profiling
of these alveolar cells or AB cells derived from wild
type or heterozygous mice that are completely normal and
non-tumor bearing, they've never seen Cre-induced tumors, we
found that these AB cells, the heterozygous AB cells,
formed two distinct clusters based on global analysis of
their chromatin accessibility landscape.
Some of these heterozygous AB cells cluster with all the wild-type AB
cells that are shown here in blue, suggesting that these are wild type-like.
But other heterozygous AB cells form a different cluster,
shown here as group two, suggesting that they have an altered
chromatin state. And interestingly, these group two
heterozygous AB cells aligned more closely with the
tumor samples, what I'll call group three, that are derived
from a different cohort of mice that have now been injected with
Cre to induce mammary tumors,
suggesting that these group two heterozygous AB cells are more
cancer-like.
And so further differential analysis of the chromatin accessibility data
revealed a unique set of chromatin regions
that showed an intermediate state of accessibility in these group two
heterozygous AB cells relative to the group one wild type-like
AB cells and the group three tumor cells with a pattern of
progressively increasing level of accessibility from group one, through
group two, to group three.And that's our
findings in ATAC-seq data. We also looked for
gene expression by single-cell RNA sequencing in the
tumors developing in the wild type for Brca1 heterozygous
background compared to normal AV cells in
young and aged mice of the two genotypes.
And we found that interestingly, many of the genes associated with these altered
chromatin regions indeed show concordant increase in gene
expression in the tumor cells, even though their expression remains
unchanged within the normal AV cells at young age or
old age across the two genotypes. And that's very interesting to
us and suggests that these
genes and chromatin regions could be primed epigenetically to
mimic the gene activation later on happening in the tumor
cells. But this priming already occurred in the normal
heterozygous AV cells before Brca1 is lost and before
tumors are formed.
And so our findings suggest that there is an expanded view
for the mechanism for early disease onset in the
Brca1 heterozygous state to accelerate cancer
development. We think that the heterozygous epithelial cells,
specifically the alveolar cells, contain open chromatin regions
that are distinct from the wild-type AV cells and are partially
mimicking the chromatin state in the tumor cells, such that
it
primes
for genes that can promote cancer formation and drive cancer
development at the early stage of disease formation.
And so this model immediately brought up a
question which is, can these open chromatin regions
reveal to us specific transcription factors as well as their
gene activation programs that can take advantage of these chromatin
changes, and drive the expression of
pro-tumorigenic genes to accelerate cancer development?
And so to address this question, we took a two-pronged approach.
We first took the partially open chromatin regions in our ATAC-seq
data and performed enrichment analysis for transcription factor binding
sites as well as motif sequences. And that immediately
revealed the enrichment of AP1 JunFos factors with
examples like c-Jun, JunD, and Fosl2.
And in parallel, we also looked at the expression of these JunFos
factors by performing immunohistochemistry staining of
breast tumor tissues and normal tissues in our mouse models.
And we saw that across the board overall, there is an increased
expression pattern of these JunFos factors.
But this is most striking in the AP1 members c-Jun,
which shows the highest level of expression in
the early malignant cells, such as the hypoplastic
regions, as well as the more well-differentiated early tumor
regions, suggesting that Jun can play a particular role in the early stage
of cancer development.
And so further interrogating the role of AP1 in tumor
formation, I made a new lentiviral construct that allows us to
partially inhibit the AP1 pathway by overexpressing
a dominant negative isoform of Jun that lacks the N-terminal
transactivation domain, and therefore it can block the function of
endogenous JunFos factors. And interestingly, when we
injected this lentivirus into the wild type and heterozygous mice that I
described earlier, we saw that this partial AP1
inhibition can delay tumor formation in the heterozygous background,
but didn't have an effect on the wild-type background, suggesting that the
heterozygous mice are more dependent on the AP1 pathway
for
early tumor onset. And this is consistent with our
ATAC-seq data showing that the AP1 binding sites are more
accessible in the heterozygous state.
And so having found AP1, we next asked a question, what
genes associated with these AP1 bound open chromatin
sites
can play a role in promoting cancer development?
And here the gene Wnt10a really caught our attention for many reasons,
including its prominent increase in chromatin accessibility in our
Group2 heterozygous AV cells, as well as substantially
elevated expression of Wnt10a in the tumor samples
compared to normal AV cells.
Additionally, there is presence of multiple Jun binding sites in the
Wnt10a locus, both in the mouse and human genomes,
and that's conserved across multiple cell types.
Additionally, there is indication of active Wnt signaling in the tumor
cells based on expression of Wnt receptors, as well as
downstream Wnt target genes. And finally, there is a
strong association between Wnt10a and human breast cancer,
specifically the basal-like breast cancer subtype relative to the other
subtypes based on analysis of human breast tissues as well as
patient-derived cell lines.
And so despite all these interesting
associations, not much was known about Wnt10a and breast cancer at the
time. And so we set off to study the role of Wnt10a
using our model systems, first by using tumor
organoids derived from our mouse models.
And that was
done by Alyssa Cordes, who is in the audience here, and
a very talented technician that is now a graduate student at UT Southwestern.
And so what Alyssa found was that if she took tumor organoids and knocked down
Wnt10a using different short hairpins, we're
able to see that now these tumor organoids have substantially
dampened Wnt signaling based on expression of downstream
genes like Axin2 and Tcf7l2. And now
these tumor organoids with Wnt10a knockdown have
substantially impaired ability to grow as tumor spheres in culture,
as well as to grow as transplant tumors in mice,
suggesting that Wnt10a is required to maintain the fitness of these
cancer cells.Additionally, when we overexpress
WNT10A to ask the effect on tumorigenesis in our
mouse models, we saw that this WNT10A overexpression is sufficient
to substantially accelerate cancer formation compared to the cohort
and also elevate the tumor grade, suggesting that WNT10A is a potent
driver of basal-like breast cancer development.
So being very much encouraged by our discovery of the role of
AP1 and also WNT10A using our approach, we then
applied the same approach to look for other transcription factors that are
revealed by this chromatin priming mechanism.
And that brought our attention to the RUNX family as well as the CBFB
cofactor, and that's an independent project led by Isabella
Kecno in my lab.
And so we found that these partially open chromatin regions that I
described earlier in the ATAC-seq data are substantially
enriched for RUNX binding sites as well as motif sequences.
And when we looked at the expression level of the RUNX and CBFB
factors now using single-cell RNA sequencing, we saw
that compared to the normal AV cells in both a
wild-type or heterozygous background at young age or older age,
the
basal-like breast cancer tumors arising in either a wild-type or
heterozygous background have substantially elevated expression of
CBFB and RUNX1, and to a lesser extent, also
RUNX2 and RUNX3.
And to further look at the expression of these factors specifically
now in the pre-malignant state, Mayura Thomas, another
talented technician, developed an organoid
model for pre-malignant cells that allowed us to
culture normal AV cells derived from either wild-type or
heterozygous mice, and then be acutely treated with
lentiCRE to delete BRCA1 and p53.
And we found that this pre-malignant model showed us
that very quickly the pre-malignant cells, upon loss of BRCA1 and
p53, elevates the expression of CBFB, and
to an even greater extent, RUNX2, suggesting that these factors can
play a role in the very stage of transformation.
So to interrogate the functional effects of these RUNX and CBFB
factors, Isabella did functional analysis by
taking cancer cell lines derived from our mouse models and knocked
down these factors using short hairpins, and
then look at the effect on cell proliferation by live-cell imaging.
And that showed us that interestingly, knockdown of CBFB
and RUNX2 substantially delayed the proliferation or
inhibited proliferation of these cells, shown here both as a time
course of the five-day proliferation as well as the endpoint confluency.
And this is representative of multiple experiments that we have done to
date. This effect of CBFB and RUNX2 is in
contrast to the knockdown of RUNX1 and RUNX3, which didn't
inhibit proliferation. And if anything, RUNX3 knockdown
actually seemed to promote proliferation of these cancer cells.
And so Isabella is now actively studying the effect of these factors in
regulating tumorigenesis in our mouse models, and also
identifying the transcription targets by
performing RNA-seq and cut-and-run analysis.
We're also studying the relevance of these RUNX and CBFB factors to
human basal-like breast cancer by analyzing tissues and performing in
vitro functional studies.
So beyond these
transcription factor programs that I have outlined to you today, our lab is
also actively studying other aspects of this chromatin priming mechanism
that I don't have time to go into details right now, but I'm very happy to talk
more about offline. And this includes the mechanisms that
drives the chromatin remodeling process, specifically in the
heterozygous alveolar cells, and how this
chromatin accessibility change relates to and impacts the
tissue and cell type specificity that we see in
BRCA1 hereditary breast cancer.
Additionally, we study how these chromatin changes interact with
physiological stress factors like pregnancy and aging and
obesity that can substantially impact breast cancer risks.
And we think that the insights gained from these studies
can help us develop better strategies for risk assessment and
also early intervention, not only in the hereditary cancer setting,
but also in the sporadic cancer setting, given the high molecular
similarities between the two forms of the same disease.
And so there are many exciting directions that we're pursuing in the lab.
And with that, I'll stop here and thank all the people who contributed to
this work, especially my former mentor, Zheng, and
her whole lab, and with a special shout-out to many talented
technicians and undergraduate students who've worked with me.
And I'll also highlight our wonderful collaborators and our sources of funding.
And in my new lab, I'm very much excited about the active ongoing
work, and I'm a proud member of the cancer research community at
Penn, including the Department of Cancer Biology, the Baser
Center for BRCA, and the Abramson Cancer Center.
And I see some of the members represented in the audience here.
Thank you for coming.
I'm grateful for the support of AACR, as well as other
foundations like the ACS and the Breakthrough Challenge Foundation.
As a new lab, we're very much open to feedback, and we're very much open to
forming new collaborations. So please don't hesitate to reach out.
And we're actively recruiting new lab members at all levels.
So if you're interested in finding out more, I'm happy to chat
anytime. And here are my contact information and lab website.
So I thank everyone for your attention and happy to take questions.
I maybe can start with one. I can see a couple of people
lining up. But I do have a couple of maybe
connected question on translation ability of the data that it's the
very elegant study that you published, and it was very well done.
And you hint a little bit about it, the next step, and how these
translate to human breast cancer.
So I was thinking, what's your opinion about it, the mouse model
that you generated, how translationable that is based on
human breast cancer, and as well as you believe that some of the
finding can later on lead to maybe early prediction
or even treatment of hereditary breast cancer.
Yeah, I think that those are good questions.
So,
in terms of what you're asking about the translatability to
human breast cancer, hereditary breast cancer, we're actively studying on that.
It's a great question. It's not an easy question to answer given the wide
degree of heterogeneity in patient tissues.
And,
one important aspect for this kind of analysis is also to account for all the
other confounding variables, such as the effect of age, the history of
pregnancy, the menopausal state, the hormonal state,
which could be challenging to account for and
in contrast to what we can do in the mouse model.
But I think this is a very important question, and we're actively working on that.
And in terms of identifying
patients that can benefit from this kind of
mechanistic insight, I think this is another question that we're
very much intrigued by because there are different levels of degree of
penetrance in BRCA1 mutation carriers in terms of cancer
risks. And it looks like that's also reflected in our mouse model as
well. And so we're also interested in understanding what dictates
this different degree of penetrance and how can we take advantage of that
to either use that as a assessment for risk and
also as a way to potentially reverse the risk or reduce the
risk for high-risk patients.
Hi, Kara Maxwell from Penn. Very happy that you're here-
Hi, Kara
... there with us now. So I have two questions, but I realize there's other people,
so I'll try to ask just the one. Do you ever see any
luminal breast cancers pop up in these models?
And if so, have you studied what's different about them?
Yeah, that's a good question. So,
as you very well know, and many other people also have reported,
that the majority of breast cancer to develop
in BRCA1 mutation carriers are the
basal type, but there is substantially a small but
significant fraction that are luminal type and are hormone receptor
positive. In our mouse model, we actually are able to capture that.
So there is a small fraction that does express hormone
receptors and
do not fully reflect a basal type. And this also is an opportunity
that we're very well aware of and very much interested in
pursuing
how these different subtypes of breast cancer
are regulated and
what's the underlying mechanism of driving that.
And I think we have very good tools to look into those questions.
Yeah.
All right. That's a very interesting talk.
I'm just curious that you show some transcription factors that their
levels were increased in the premalignant state.
Mm-hmm.
What's the reason for their level being increased in that state?
Is there any thought? What drive their upregulation in the
premalignant state?
Yeah.
That's one. Second is that-
Yeah
... are some of the transcription factors themself causal if you don't have the
genetic change and just make them slightly
higher
in the normal mice? Is that enough to cause tumor?
Hmm.
Two questions. Thank you.
Right. So in terms of your first question, what drives the activation of
these transcription factors in the early stage of cancer formation?
I think there are a variety of causes for that, specifically in the context of
AP1, it's been well established that it's a stress responsive
transcription factor. So we think that the oncogenic stress at the beginning of
BRCA1 and p53 laws can induce the AP1 and has
been well documented in many other cancer types, including
basal-like breast cancer.
In terms of your second question of using these factors
alone to promote cancer formation, I think while they can be potent
drivers, I think they probably are insufficient.
Genetic alterations in combination with gene expression changes and
epigenetic changes,
in my opinion, would be working together to drive the process.
Thank you.
Thank you. In the back.
Hi, Carmen. Great talk.
Hi, thank you.
I have something, a question you partially addressed.
So because if you insight this stress response
kind of transcription factor, do you see continue those site being
enriched in the tumor, full-blown tumor, or is it
only the transition stage at the heterozygous condition?
So many of those sites are also present,
meaning they are also open in the tumors.
Okay.
And in many cases, they actually are further open.
So the degree of accessibility further increase in the same sites,
but they're partially open already in the heterozygous
normal epithelial cells.
Okay. A short question related with that.
Do you also see tumor extrinsic effect, for example,
immune system being influenced in the heterozygous state?
Yeah, I think this is a very interesting question, and there
are other groups that have reported
effect on stromal cells such as the fibroblasts or pericytes and
other cells that can have a crosstalk with epithelial cells.
We've tried to look ourselves and,
at least in our hands, we haven't had very striking evidence of that.
But I think
the studies that
have been reported are mostly done with patient materials and that are
exposed with much higher physiological stress.
And so I think that
perhaps in combination with stress factors in our models, those
phenotypes might be more prominent.
Great. Thanks.
Just very quickly, I was curious whether you think or
have investigated a role for R-loops in these specific
targets since BRCA1 deficiency has been tied to
accumulation of R-loops.
Yeah, that's a good question.
We have not been actively looking at that.
But certainly, that's something that would be very interesting to look at.
Thanks.
Yeah. If there are no more questions, thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you very much for
questions.
It was really very nice to